and our local hero Eddie whoo I'm
pleased to say joins Kyra and I now from
Canberra after a night of celebrations
and you wake up this morning as our
local hero any whoo for those who don't
know and I guess we're all just starting
to learn more about it I know you've got
a hundred thousand subscribers and eight
million people worldwide have watched
you but tell us about whoo - what is it
look the simplest way I can give you a
picture is that if you want to sit in a
classroom that's a normal school around
the country sit right in the middle look
right at the whiteboard and that's what
you can see on my channel it's
completely transparent my students are
there sitting all around the camera and
you can see that you know halfway
through the video I sort of have to
pause and say oh look Johnny
the deputy principals come called you
down to the office so it's exactly
transparent and normal experience of
what my classroom is like now you
started this to help one of your
students who was sick and it's just well
it's grown incredibly since could you
have imagined just a couple of years ago
that you'd end up here this morning a
parliament house canberra a local hero
in the Australia Day Awards you say a
couple of years ago I still can't
believe it and you can definitely tell
if you have a look at some of my older
videos there was no plan for a grand
sort of media stage or anything like
that it's all really lo-fi and I one of
the things I loved about it is that I
get to just share the normal experience
of my students and the normal experience
of what happens in schools around the
country I very wholeheartedly believe
there's nothing extraordinary about my
classroom but what you get to see on the
channel is the hard work and dedication
of teachers around the country working
for the sake of their students and
you've already got quite a platform as
it is but this local hero award what do
you think that gives you you know extra
that you can use this year what do you
want to do with with that honour that
platform
there are two big things that come to my
mind I really want to make sure that
education has a new kind of perspective
from students teachers parents and
politicians and also about mathematics
which obviously is my subject when it
comes to education I want everyone to
value the way that schools work and can
transform communities I think that
sometimes we fall into the trap of just
taking education for granted because
it's just everywhere in our country when
we forget that around the world that's
not always the case so I really want
schools and educators to be valued
really deeply and honored because I
think that's the way we're going to have
the best teachers and that's the way
that society is going to benefit when it
comes to mathematics yeah I don't people
to understand that it's for everyone you
know it's a subject that just like
literacy is something that you know it
deepens enriched enriches your life in a
way that you can't really comprehend if
you're someone who can't read and then
when you can interpret the world around
you it just unlocks an entire universe
and that's the way I think of
mathematics yeah well let's hope that
you make great progress in that it's a
wonderful endeavor that you hope to or
pursue over the next year with this new
award at en give us a sense for our
viewers to smell your own personal story
though because with your ability you
could have gone in well basically into
any career and thankfully for your
students at Cherry Book Technical High
School
you chose teaching
for me when I was in the wonderful
position of having the ability to choose
you know what would I do with my life
the first thing that I that came to mind
was just gratitude you know that's the
reason why my parents moved to this
country where my brother and sister were
born here because this really genuinely
is a land of opportunity I mean we had
our challenges when we were growing up
it was really difficult sort of working
with the discrimination that is just
normal when you kind of are an immigrant
the child of an immigrant and you're
trying to work out where do you fit in
and the people around you are also
trying to work out where you fit in
but coming through that recognizing that
this is a land of amazing platforms and
choices once you have an education in
some ways that's what was the tipping
point I realized I'd been given a
precious gift that education had opened
doors to me that I would never have
dreamed and I wanted to share that with
people around the country in the next
generation deserves people who
absolutely champion them and can help
them get the support that they need to
you know do whatever their career is
that they can dream of I've seen your
father outright say he was hoping you'd
become a lawyer or or a doctor in fact
as he come around so you know exactly
seeing on the stand what's your on the
TV
do you think he's come around that you
made the right choice I'm very fortunate
that while I think my dad dreams of
things like that he um he did give me
the choice to say I'm gonna pursue this
and I just hope that this really honors
him and that it shows you know what if
you have a heart for serving people
around you that's the real reason that
I'm a teacher you know whatever people
want to do if you want to be a nurse if
you want to be a chef and engineer if
you want to work in the media if you're
serving a community then what you're
doing is important and you should do it
with all your heart if you do that then
all of us Australians can make a society
that we can all be proud of
well we congratulate you Eddie whoo and
I also wish all the very best to the
enrollment officer at cherrybrook
Technical High School because when
parents see this gentleman in action
heymy busy they're gonna be very busy
that's fun Eddie whoo have a wonderful
Australia Day congratulations on
everything you've achieved in on this
this wonderful recognition this morning
thanks so much happy Australia Day to
you too